peter liese ist uns nun auch
zugeschaltet gesundheitspolitiker
diese sagen sie uns wie sehen sie
momentan die entwicklung in deutschland
vor allem im blick auf den lockt der
verlängert wird als einer der
hauptgründe dafür wird die mutationen
oder die verschiedene mutationen
angeführt ja ich glaube wir müssen nach
wie vor sehr vorsichtig sein und kann
auch die bayerische staatsregierung
darin unterstützen denn ich habe leider
mit ansehen müssen wie die entwicklung
in irland war in den letzten wochen ihr
land bei einer super situation wir
hatten
fast keine infektion mehr es gab tage an
denen bei 5 millionen einwohnern in
irland niemand ankurbelt 19 gestorben
ist
und dann haben sie zu schnell zu viel
geöffnet und die britische mutationen
dazu bekommen und dann haben sich die
zahlen innerhalb eines monates mehr als
verzehnfacht wenn man das dann nach
bestimmten tag rechnet sogar für 18 fach
noch schlimmer war es in portugal wir
sind von einem höheren niveau gestartet
und dann haben sich die zahlen da
verachtfacht jetzt ist die bundeswehr in
portugal
weil es dort notwendig ist zu helfen vor
vier fünf wochen noch leute in
deutschland gesagt guck doch nach
portugal da kann man doch auch alles
öffnen warum können wir das nicht wir
sollten das nicht zu früh tun ich bin
für sehr gezielte öffnung und dass die
schulen eine priorität haben
bei gezielten öffnungen mit ganz
strengen kontrollen ist sicher richtig
aber wir wollten nicht dass alles
verspielen was wir jetzt erreicht haben
eine dritte welle wäre für uns alle
schlimmer als jetzt noch ein bisschen
durchzuhalten early check wie muss man
sich das vorstellen wie jetzt da
verhandelt wird wir wissen ja dass
bayern hat es baden-württemberg hart ist
und da hat man sich schon verhakt vorher
so ein bisschen in der vorbesprechung
und da ging es dann darum eben was die
frage der öffnungs perspektive ist jetzt
hat sich herr kretschmann schon geäußert
hat gesagt er ist mehr oder weniger
enttäuscht von der kanzlerin dass sie da
von ihrer harten die hier so ein
bisschen abgerückt ist was muss aus
ihrer sicht passieren dass sich die
bayerische position durchsetzen kann
dass sie sozusagen
dabei bleibt das was sie ja wollten dass
sie schon im nicht geöffnet werden
also ich hab gesagt man muss das genau
beobachten wann die schulen geöffnet
werden können und ich glaube die
bayerische position ist eine position
der vernunft die orientiert sich an dem
schutz der menschen das ist unsere
grundsätzliche position und von der
wollen wir auch nicht abweichen
natürlich brauchen wir perspektiven die
auch nachhaltig sind das heißt kein
mensch will heute zu machen morgen
wieder aufmachen und unter dieser
prämisse erwarte ich diese diskussionen
die faktenlage zu bewerten wie es gerade
beschrieben worden ist die gefahr der
mutation auf der anderen seite den
menschen zu sagen wenn wir jetzt noch
durchhalten dann schaffen wir es auf
sehr niedrige incidence werte zu kommen
von denen ausgehend wir dann tatsächlich
auch wieder ein stück normalität ins
leben der menschen zurückbringen können
wir alle wollen doch dasselbe
letztendlich es geht darum dinge zu
vereinen die im moment sich nicht als
widerspruch gegenüber stehen aber so
wahrgenommen werden die gesundheit der
menschen und die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung des landes für mich ist das
kein widerspruch sondern beides muss
zusammen kommen und das ist unser weg
und den wollen wir vertreten
diese in wahrheit ist es ja so dass wir
keine perspektive in deutschland haben
dass alle die
hoffnung verlieren weil sie es beim
impfstoff alle zusammen versammelt haben
wir haben nicht genug impfstoff in
europa wir haben nicht noch impfstoff in
deutschland und wenn wir uns das
anschauen die deutsche statistik wir
sind da auf einem abstiegsplatz sind sie
gescheitert mit ihrer politik also da
würde ich jetzt wirklich mal an ihrer
stelle den mund nicht so voll nehmen
wenn die bild -zeitung nicht im herbst
die guten vorschläge die markus söder
und angela merkel gemacht haben um
dieses virus um griff zu bekommen
dann stehen wir jetzt nicht so schlecht
da das heißt ich hätte ich rede über die
impfstoff statistik und da können sie
hilft dafür meine frage ist was mit der
impfung mit dem impfstoff sagen wir
leben in einem freien land
naja wie das system und deswegen
kritisieren wir auch deswegen
kritisieren wir auch jeden tag wie
katastrophal die europäische union die
impfstoff bestellung gemanagt hat
zusammen mit der bundeskanzlerin angela
merkel heute katastrophal wir da stehen
in dem vergleich wie katastrophal die
gesamte situation ist und deswegen meine
frage wieso ist das so schief gegangen
ich kritisiere jeden tag die bild
zeitung und ich habe auch mit dem chef
des springer verlags über diese frage
gesprochen und auf meine einschätzung
als arzt und als jemand der die
situation seit langem auch in europa
beobachtet dass auch die bild zeitung
neben vielen anderen eine verantwortung
hat für die 60.000 toten die wir jetzt
in deutschland haben hatte bin ich
gesagt herr liebe das ist völliger
unsinn und da muss man noch nicht mal
drüber nachdenken und deswegen nehme ich
mir die freiheit darüber zu sprechen im
vorgespräch wurde mir gesagt wir reden
über die dinge die gerade heute in
deutschland zu entscheiden sind und wenn
sie jetzt sagen ich soll was zurzeit um
die leute jeder entscheider hat
deutschland die heute getroffen wird hat
mit dem versagen der europäischen union
weil impfstoff zu tun und deswegen meine
frage warum ist das so schief gegangen
und natürlich die bild -zeitung jeden
tag kritisieren sie können auch den
vorstandsvorsitzenden anrufen das ändert
nichts daran dass bild jeden tag
weiterhin darauf zeigen wird was bei der
impfstoff bestellung falsch läuft
und jetzt wollen wir mal über die sache
reden sie sagen deutschland ist auf
einen abstiegsplatz
die bild zeitung und auch leider bild
leipzig
kann es nicht ändern bei steigendem
zuschauern und den zuhörern und den
lesern jeden tag viele wahrheiten es
wird gesagt dass kanada schneller
bestellt hat und mehr bestellt hat kann
er kriegt aber weniger impfstoff als
deutschland die liegen bei den zahlen
der geimpften hinter deutschland haben
wir darauf eine antwort
können sie mir das mal erklären warum
ihre these da nicht zutrifft in kanada
das wäre er lerne ich weiß nicht über
welche these sie jetzt gerade sprechen
wollen sie brauchen sich die statistik
nur einmal anschauen da sehen sie dass
deutschland ist acer kann ein paar
rumänien steht ja ich habe doch gar
nicht über kanada gesprochen
ich hatte schon als brauche ich hab
gerade darüber gesprochen dass in
großbritannien das in großbritannien die
menschen sich auf den sommer freuen weil
sie urlaub machen können und wir
deutschen wahrscheinlich richtig alt
aussehen werden und nirgendwohin fliegen
können weil sie ist versammelt haben mit
der impfstoff bestellung also erstens
habe ich den impfstoff nicht bestellt
genauso wenig wie dafür war das
bundesgesundheitsministerium in
kooperation mit der europäischen
kommission zuständig und dann bitte eine
entschuldigung an die zuschauer mehr ist
hier gesagt worden dass wir über das
thema reden was jetzt in deutschland zu
passieren hat und nicht über
irgendwelche beschuldigung und deswegen
entschuldige sich der us riese oder was
ist das mit jedem aber warum wollen sie
nicht beantworten warum beziehen sie
sich hier auf dem vorgespräch und sagen
sie wollen eigentlich immer im stoff
reden
ich kann gerne in über impfstoff reden
in der bild zeitung und in anderen
erzeugnissen des springer-verlages dann
deutschland hat so machen sollen wie
kanada also warum vortragsreihen und
großbritannien und die usa verwiesen
für mich und meine kommentare ja aber
ich habe an ihren den mund genommen
wenn wir wollen abstiegsplatz reden auf
den abstiegsplätzen stehen japan wir
können jetzt erstrahlen können jetzt
gleich noch einmal die statistik sei
dann gerne in der sendung wo wieder das
sagen hat platz stehen zeigen sie bitte
mal wo japan steht sagen jetzt nicht mit
anderen anfang
manchmal haben sie sind auch alle wir
können dich mit anderen
ich denke dass großbritannien sich mit
den allerschlechtesten vergleichen wenn
das deutschlands anspruch wäre dann
würden wir aber als als land auch
wirtschaftlich sehr schlecht dastehen in
der zukunft wenn wir uns jetzt mit dem
letzten platz vergleichen also jetzt
noch mal ganz von vorne ist es geht
nicht darum sich mit dem schlechten zu
vergleichen war wenn die wagen
abstiegsplatz dann ist das einfach
taktisch falsch weil bei der bundesliga
gibt es 18 vereine auf der welt gibt es
200 länder und das werden wir alle armen
länder rausrechnen steht deutschland gut
im mittelfeld wir sind sogar bei der
zweite impfung besser als großbritannien
weil wir diese riskante strategie zu
sagen wir impfen nur einmal
obwohl es empfohlen ist und nach allen
daten notwendig ist ein zweites mal zu
impfen weil dass großbritannien nicht
macht und deutschland nach vorsichtiger
und seriöser aber warum hatte - da gibt
es statistiken von der oxford university
unter anderem die sonst recht gebrauch
ich möchte zum abschluss einfach nur
eine sache verstehen vielleicht können
sie mir das als egal ich lernen dadurch
diese statistik mal kurz erwähnen
bezieht sich auf den impfstoff von
astrazeneca der in deutschland erst seit
dieser woche für investiert um die
strecke weiter zu sagen - und weise der
streckung impfung bei der bekämpfung
gibt es diese statistiken also wenn sie
sind immerhin auch immer noch darauf
ausruhen wollen dass wir angeblich viel
seriöser und eine bessere zulassung
haben okay meine frage an sie wieso
stehen wir denn als europäische union
nach dem rexit dann nach dem was
passiert ist warum stehen wir so
schlecht da im vergleich zumindest zu
den usa zu großbritannien und zu israel
erklären sie mir das doch mal also
zunächst einmal das wissen sie wenn sie
sich um diese frage gekümmert haben
israel hat einen ganz speziellen deal
selbst der im vorstand von biontech für
den verkauf und impfstoff zuständig ist
schon meldet hat gesagt er weiß nicht
wie der deal zustande gekommen ist das
ist eine persönliche entscheidung des
pfizer chefs gewesen und die israelische
experten die mit mir über diese
impfstoff frage gesprochen dann sagen
kein anderes land der welt auch nicht
deutschland hätte einen solchen deal
bekommen das ist ganz klar ein amazon
besser der andeuten was soll das für die
gewesen sein
warum kriegen wir da hin weil es zb
darum ging dass israel seit vielen
jahren sehr viel großzügiger ist beim
datenschutz und ich weiß nicht ob das
die deutsche bevölkerung gut gefunden
hätte auf jeden fall wurde diese
diskussion nicht geführt es hat von
pfizer kein angebot an deutschland
gegeben es ist eine ganz persönliche
sache gewesen wenn der biontech vorstand
der für verkauf von impfstoff
zuständigen es nicht erklären kann was
da genau passiert ist dann gehen wir der
sache doch bitte mal nach ich berge
wiesen die letten wir nicht machen
können selbst wenn wir nicht in der eu
gewesen werden und man an nichts
ansonsten abgehalten hätten
der zweite punkt die usa ein
exportverbot wir haben entschieden dass
nichts rauskommt
und in dem moment als die eu gemacht hat
wir müssen auch über
exportbeschränkungen zunächst mal
nachdenken es kann doch nicht sein dass
die ganze welt aus der eu versorgt wird
und dass dann die der rest der welt
nichts nach europa reinlässt
gab es leider auch in ihren redaktionen
sehr viel kritik an der eu und nicht an
den usa oder in großbritannien die es
offensichtlich normal finden dass aus
der eu die welt versorgt wird und die
briten und die amerikaner nichts in
andere länder lassen ich denke das muss
doch mal thematisiert werden hier haben
wir ein riesenproblem dass daher ließen
wenn ich darauf legen sie sie reden sich
daraus und und die eu hat nichts falsch
gemacht oder wie sich das für einen sinn
wenn du das schon alleine tor gestellt
und der jetzt sparen und die kanzlerin
und sowieso wichtigen ganz großartig da
weil wir nicht so schlecht sind wie
japan und kanada also ist das wirklich
ihre einstellung
wenn sie mich mal ausreden lassen würden
wenn sie eine chance der schweiz zu
erklären ich glaube der fehler der
gemacht wurde ist dass man tatenlos
zugesehen hat als die amerikaner ein
exportverbot gemacht haben und dass man
dann auch immer noch tatenlos zugesehen
hat als der impfstoff von biontech und
scheiber nach großbritannien ging und
dann allen ernstes wie briten behaupten
es wäre nicht in ordnung wenn der
impfstoff von astrazeneca von
großbritannien in die eu kommt ich
glaube das war ein fehler und wenn wir
da mal genauer hinschauen würden anstatt
dann auch noch die eu zu kritisieren
wenn sie export begrenzung macht wir
brauchen den impfstoff hier und es kann
nicht sein dass der unkontrolliert in
anderen ländern geht zum beispiel nach
dubai wo sich reiche menschen von 46.000
euro münzen lassen es war höchste zeit
dieses exportverbot und wenn wir über
fehler reden das ist sicherlich der
wichtigsten fehler dass man da nicht
früher strenge begrenzung gemacht hat
aber leider wurde die eu dafür dann auch
wieder kritisiert dass überhaupt
exportkontrollen macht und ich finde das
ist nicht in ordnung
elisa herzlichen dank dass sie sich
unseren fragen gestellt haben denn das
ist glaube ich wichtig in dieser zeit
dass man auch streitet in der
öffentlichkeit und dass die menschen
antworten bekommen auf die fragen und
herzlichen dank dafür
ok
[Applaus]